So far we have discussed block ciphers,
which take as an input
a fixed length data block,
say in 64-bit 40 years,
or 128-bit for 8 years.
What if you want to encrypt
a large message, that is,
a message that's longer than 64-bit,
or even 128-bit?
The solution seems obvious.
Why can't we just break a message
into fixed-size blocks,
apply a block cipher such as DES or
AES on the blocks, then
the collection of the ciphertext blocks
is the ciphertext of the large message?
Is that it?
This seems to be very simple.
Let's take a look at a few schemes
that encrypt a large message.
The simplest way is the so-called
electronic code book method or ECB.
Here, the original large message is
broken down into fixed-sized blocks,
say 64-bit, and we pad the last block so
that it is also 64-bit.
And then each plaintext block
is encrypted using the same key
independently of each other.
And the collection of these ciphertext
blocks is the ciphertext of the original
large message.
The term code book is used, because for
given key, there is a unique ciphertext
block for every plaintext block.
Therefore, we can construct
a gigantic code book
in which there's an entry for
every possible plaintext block, and
the table entry shows
the corresponding ciphertext block.
Of course,
we construct one code book for each key.
In practice, only the plaintext blocks
that are used in an application
need to be included in the code book.
That is, the code book does not need to
include all possible plaintext blocks.
Therefore, it does not
have to be gigantic.
So this seems to be a very convenient
of encrypting a large message.